hello and welcome to best
LittleBigPlanet 3 levels of the wisher
with the catchy name I that's a mouthful
we have partnered up with Sony to bring
you guys the very best creator the top
tier levels that have come out of your
mind ba creme de la creme oh yes in
LittleBigPlanet 3 speaking of creme de
la creme this is set forth the word
Smith yes you can hear channel speaker
I'm also the other coast cab Robertsons
but with the third piece of this
glorious puzzle Lizzy James yes we're
gonna do this for the next four weeks
that's gonna involve us basically
playing every single level we can get
our hands on that you guys are made in
the community and you know just like
separating the wheat from the chaff at
the gold from the bugs whether the show
is called the best oh yeah we do need
ring all in dress one to them yeah but
there are there are a few buggy ones
there are some some second places some
certain runner-up a man as my mum was
used to saying bronze medals still a
medal yeah well it is yeah very
encouraging couple old mama Robinson
there yeah but we have found three
awesome levels yes some level over out
of the first week of this game being
else so how about we crack into level
number one let's do it
welcome to my pod can hi Sam I'm a
dashing one er it with the desert door I
just punched you see how nice you in
your pod that hard we think it a punch
see here good that's dancing with it
whether you do what what their crime
ring you in home what is it
look you've had like a horrible wrath
beard
this is awful don't know done enough but
don't you want some electrical whine now
I took any electrical wire
what map we do for the community matter
face is it the eventually matter face
and then we go and seeing as we're
looking for our first level you probably
only want to be finding games and levels
from LittleBigPlanet 3 yeah do that you
want to come in here and click the light
stick in you can uncheck all the old
games from your search cursory copies
copies copies apiece apiece cursory
curious curious codpiece
go this is a curious cos piece it is
curious what we know the same hold on we
need to change changing ok key change ok
you can keep the cowboy because you
clearly seem to like him I'm where I'm
gonna wear my sketches and let's go up
we know where to jump there hold on come
back good we broke the game
here we go the game boy go go go come on
here we go
ok I'm having free stuff ok don't die
now so if we if we don't go together
then now you gotta get green stuff is
bad greased-up a faster nice are you
good bouncing so one of the things like
they noticed about about playing these
user-made levels so sometimes when you
die when they thought when they know
they've got no thing yeah
you can't ever continue but this guy
shoot designed a level where it is
possible so what we've done here is
we've broken the game so he document
this is how it goes we just do this
Freitas
let's go again it's not a bug it's a
feature you picture odd sock as a horse
or more of a dog uh I think he's more of
a dog in general but my one looks like a
horse no because of the way I've dressed
it all the green is bad we've got the
green was bad
alright whatever you do oh nice Oh
oh my god dirty lady go horsey
if this were a race we'd be doing real
bad oh no I died it was all on you pal
oh that's how you do it
oh thanks Sarah it's hip not you jump
see vigorously off it that's your
problem Sam they're always too vigorous
is my middle name you weigh them at the
end so he won yes me I did yeah
fifty you don't like to dance you lost
you lost did you oh you did I wait how
did you win because I was better it's
hard it that was fun you got a heart
did we hot it was just on hard right
yeah okay good job alright Dedmon if
you're watching this can you please we
know in the level two curious codpiece
happy wandering I just save everyone
some time but what's behind to move on
to level number two so what's next sev
alright sab I don't know if we're both
in here look at the spanner on my face
look at you've done it's okay can be sad
um all right so who's first
till my left stick I've got the person
on the lower screen on my right the
first person I've got the
toggle on fish fish the door yeah door
push good job and on the right stick
yeah but the top just gonna show getting
toggles abilities but also you have to
like some good stick control yes alright
I think I'm doing all right yeah you
know it is punching a thing that he does
okay sure
ah the other way the other way Oh quick
toggle Oh keep it bites oh oh
pain oh um how did I win I do anything
what haha what I do anything i won
alright now counting charge okay how'd
you talk oh uh buds 25 any buds three
buds
rubbish you know worst yeah all right
I'm calling that practice round okay
again this this is the real you major
league okay
this is Major these rolling upstairs
learning all those minutes of training
we did a few minutes ago well it comes
in you're doing it all wrong yeah well
laughs I'm certainly fun I shouldn't
have hurt you should to help you thank
you friend
it's alright don't ever think the other
thing ever think I can solve I got that
five three six five three Monday but
again ah fight with you both you need
both ha ha ha ha ha ha ha 395 suck it is
so that's one round to me I'll take that
it's not a rillette um not yet but the
thing is is very good bit more I'll swab
again much okay who stayed up school
less 47 47 give me that oh that's good
that was hard little guy yeah 5 3 6 I
still won Oh
all right deciding Rome hooray that's
his victory late cuz he's know he's
about to win well we'll see this all
comes down to this set 500 oh no seven
alright I got it before I skip that's
Kevin okay to speak so what's your
favorite left or right ah you're a
righty gosh you more of a loud how
things have do you like big toggle or
little things themselves in the question
do you like pushing walls of going
through holes then you are uh yeah
still five three six how how you always
get five to six and why I always get
four seven because I'm consistently
slightly slightly barely only slightly
you are the worst alright well I think
the scoreboard I think you you take that
one alright that one was burn blocks hmm
or LBP 3oc Bernbach by rile ruiz rile
remarries that was good one Rosie's guy
I mean that was really hard but he's a
good guy nonetheless second lap four
crazy men and very dangerous and very
dead very danger ok well let's keep an
eye on the end because if the end is as
danger as it suggests I know very danger
okay down here
this spanner is really getting started
getting the windows what you maybe you
need a new spanner no I don't know
get on your bike Oh God my name is Shane
oh good let me go I can be good your
bike yeah do what Oh what what yes yes
why is it character following you it's
it's full of making your mind
I don't know how did I die what what all
the keys but I wanted fit very danger
keys yeah
don't understand okay it's okay okay
too much team are you like it's okay
I've lost a wheel yeah get my god yeah
yeah hold on yeah driving test all over
again
yeah you made it well done again yet
again again very dangerous very
dangerous very dangerous
yeah crazy oh yeah Oh soon as your hands
onions a party here that's right alright
you can come you know it's another right
yes come on it's better face almost
better fit so I think I'm taking the
lead how I don't know I need slack of
spanner oh yes banners really slow me
down
come on right I hear the end is Right
danger oh god yeah no whichever the fire
and the fire the able to I won yes the
camera phone Oh God come on little guy
like what dude dead oh no he's dead oh
he's dead wow this is very this is very
very day today feel like I'm going right
an instant
doing something that should be doing oh
hey we won all that was the very
dangerous no I want to decorate your
bike but you need driving dice there are
you not there game we both we both get
we both get extra extra things you like
you for example get um get this look you
need a steering wheel for your bike
come on ahead done to my bike I gave you
a steering wheel are you gauging right I
gave you an S for Sam I was so kind I
made you a while ago yeah look better
Kevin Foster it isn't me look at the
estimate on your back wheel though oh
come on
weird bite it's totally getting away of
everything doc crap just stop Oh
you let go the steering wheel made done
putting a little little odd sock on the
back of my bike for a chisel a nice big
bag no I don't want poker on my baby
nice big place it gets everywhere
popcorn slows me down
popcorn helps no liquor so I am oh good
maybe helps no no no no no no come on
come on little total - total you gotta
help me out here not slowing down for
anything
what are you killed me again today maybe
you killed you have you considered an
insistence on slowing down tells me it
was the partnership boy wait wait wait
look I know it kills you no I want no
it's not kill me at all cuz I'm gonna
take your bike what hahahahaha oh you
actually got the bike through to the end
I sure did I love a nice bike is either
on or off whoops hey oh oh no it crushed
me
Oh God that doesn't seem entirely fair
you know
oh all right I'll concede you want that
one yeah forget that was bikes in the
danger zone in ice an infernal race guys
right it's really really dangerous very
dangerous second cycle per second lab
very very danger that's my favorite so
far today I must submit
that was awesome but the important thing
is I won all three which means I am the
greatest yes but I just run on those
maps if you want to see me beat Seb on
other maps the best way to do that is to
send them to us yes you do that you too
buddy tweeting as for the best way
tweeting at me at camp for Azeroth or at
him at Ready Steady Go
yep or the hashtag which is that is GS
lb p3
yes which is short for not just
gibberish GameSpot LittleBigPlanet free
remember that while you write it it
takes up to mediator beep letters and
then just like and you can say questions
in there if you have any questions for
us or about show lobby where how about I
know I was robbed of my victory but
sings we don't have any questions or
comments for this the first episode
Cameron I prepared questions for you oh
and they form of a diss all that Damon a
this no I choose this wrong you must
answer quickly camera it is
LittleBigPlanet themes here we go I'm
ready question 1 sack boy or game boy
sack by England or Scotland Scotland ken
block or odd sock odd such several ec
save somewhere warm molecule what see
you my will molecule molecule
pumpkinator a terminator terminator
cybernetic company guards
fryer lorry lorry old Sacco Hitchcock
it's go games or Dame's Dave's DaVinci
or Newton DaVinci Buncombe or Peckham
back up daddy or chips chips
swoop toggle or Snoop Dogg 'el Steve dog
oh all right
there questions done that was great
terrible building levels great at asking
questions yeah but you guys are even
better at asking questions and building
levels so if you could do both again
yeah we'd really appreciate that if I
had that creativity in in fact it'd be
great to have another this or that
session next week if you have any this
or that questions send them to us you
have the power
existence capable of the show you know
what this or that next week for several
Lucy and the answer is act even though I
said Savin the questions you did next
week gets Lucy because if you are not
you know at least he's going to do it
thing the hot seat is it's kind of
winner stays on at the moment
that's right you so you must be mostly
yes well hopefully she is better than I
am and she cannot cam off the throne all
right we will be back here Wednesday
next week we'll see you there